eric decosta the ravens general manager
we touched earlier on the fact that
lamar jackson is one of the quarterbacks
on deck for a new contract three years
in he has proven he's a great
quarterback and this is a dilemma for
the ravens if he doesn't have an agent
how far shireen do you push this how
much do you take advantage of the
situation if it's not a skilled and
seasoned agent who understands the
nuances of the contract there's talk
that it's going to be
lamar jackson's mom
and her lawyer and just because you get
a lawyer involved that doesn't mean the
lawyer understands lawyers think they
can figure anything out trust me i was
one but that doesn't mean you can't
figure it out you act like you know and
then you're kind of like well maybe i
don't know but i'll act like i know and
that's half the battle you need people
who really do know
how the sausage has gotten made in other
cases and in a situation like this you
can end up with a deal that looks really
good on paper but then when you start
picking around the details it's not
nearly as good and you've got the
template now with dak prescott's deal
but you know the difference is lamar
jackson
isn't anywhere close to having the
leverage that dak prescott had that's
the leverage that you have when you're
in the second year of your franchise tag
knowing that there can't be a third
franchise tag so lamar jackson
really has
two more years under his rookie deal
and then
another year after that he's four years
away three years away from being in the
same position that prescott's in and he
could do what that didn't say no i'm not
doing a deal no i'm not doing a deal no
i'm not doing a deal so he's at the
front end of something that dak had to
deal with and he has to deal with it for
one more year because he's going to be
under contract for five years under his
rookie deal instead of four so this is
not going to be easy and the sooner it
gets done the cheaper it's necessarily
going to be for the team
and i do think that's where you need
somebody to advise you mike somebody who
knows what they're doing because
otherwise i could see dak prescott
signing a deal way back when that wasn't
nearly as good as as what he got
yesterday and so
lamar jackson does need some good advice
whoever that comes from he needs to seek
it out and and figure out how he's going
to get this deal done and when he's
going to get this deal done so hopefully
he has somebody advising him who knows
what they're doing if not i could
definitely see the ravens getting a good
deal a much better deal than they should
out of lamar jackson
yeah and uh
look
i don't think dak prescott went into his
negotiations in 2019 saying i'm going to
say no and i'm going to say no and i'm
going to play this out and i'm going to
end up making a ton of money a couple of
years from now i think the cowboys made
it easier for him because they didn't
make him an offer he couldn't refuse and
when you're lamar jackson you've got a
physical playing style and yes he's been
able to stay healthy so far but you can
use that to your advantage it's all
about what you put on the table that he
will or won't say yes to it's how
risk-averse is he when it comes to his
money does he want that generational
payday does he want it even if it's less
than what it would be if he pushed it to
the limit these are all things that need
to be worked out between
lamar
whoever is advising him and the ravens
but i can understand why the ravens want
to do it now because it's always more
expensive the longer you wait if they're
sold on lamar jackson and they they
basically reconfigured their offense
around him so they need him if they're
sold on this guy and they're not
concerned about getting two years out
from signing to a long-term deal like
the eagles and the rams did with winston
goff and saying what the hell did we do
then swoop in
make him an offer he can't refuse now so
you don't
start on that path toward franchise tag
one franchise tag two
and you basically are over and in and
under a barrel like the cowboys were
with dak prescott
and you better be sure mike i mean we
use the carson wins and jared goff as
cautionary tales right and this guy has
had one good year frankly they were not
very good passing wise last year they
won some games they got to the playoffs
lamar jackson has not been good in the
postseason one and three in the
postseason even though his regular
season record is terrific he's gotten
with the playoffs every single season
be sure that this is the guy who's going
to lead you to the super bowl before you
commit the money we saw with joe flacco
right they gave him the big money after
the super bowl the mvp award and frankly
he didn't live up to that contract after
i know why they did it i get it i
understand it if they had it to do over
again and could see into the future they
wouldn't have given joe flacco that
contract
that was the last time a team was in the
same kind of compromised position that
the cowboys were in with dak and the
ravens have learned from that they're
not going to let themselves get into
that trap again where they have no
choice but to break the bank they can
they can fracture the bank but not flat
out break it and make lamar jackson
happy and i think they're going to be
motivated to do it all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports